el ministerio del interior había instado
a los rusos a abstenerse de participar
en estas protestas no autorizadas
mientras expertos en derechos humanos de
la onu avisaron de que el líder opositor
aleccionaban lee está en serio peligro y
por eso pidieron al gobierno ruso que
permitiese que fuese trasladado al
extranjero para ser tratado allí el
político de la oposición está enfermo en
prisión lleva en huelga de hambre ya
tres semanas para exigir tener acceso a
sus propios médicos en moscú la policía
selló la céntrica plaza pushkin al lugar
de encuentro en estas manifestaciones
los pocos más de 10.000 manifestantes
que se dieron cita sólo podían pasear
calle arriba la larga avenida actores
acá ya la policía evitó que hubiese
cortes de tráfico aunque muchos coches
tocaban el claxon sumándose a la
protesta una hora antes de que empezase
la gran manifestación en moscú ya había
300 detenidos en todo el país al final
más de 1000 arrestados en esta jornada
de protestas en toda rusia